Hey dude, did you know since Trump got rid of rose,
some states may revert back to laws
that almost totally outlash remorse?
In Arizona, that law dates back to 1864.
Letting Trump in that project
2025 could literally send women's progress back to the wild, wild West.
Howdy. Sorry for delay.
There's a little surge pressing on my horse carriage over here.
But let's take a look at you.
Wait, you're my doctor?
This here is my assistant.
Does he have a medical degree?
They didn't really have an education like that back then.
Will my insurance cover this?
What's that? My ass insurance is that?
A little spoonful of mercury will probably set you right.
They really did that?
Restricting reproductive rights to the Abraham Lincoln era
has cascading effects on women's economic and educational prospects.
So if he packs the court again,
all legal protections are at risk when it comes to discrimination.
I mean, if that's bothering you
should probably just rub a little mustard on it.
This affects men too. If women don't have control over their bodies,
a lot more men are going to become early baby daddies.
Or maybe have to wear a condom forever.
There's a ton of reasons why men shouldn't pull out of this election.
Hold on, I'm jotting this down.
Now you just go to wild wild west dot.
I will vote com for voter information.
I will vote com for information.